Lo que hemos representado aquí en estas cuatro
imágenes es materia en diferentes estados,
y estamos usando lo que se conoce como modelos
de partículas. Estos son modelos de partículas
bidimensionales, son formas sencillas de imaginar
lo que está sucediendo dentro de la materia a
escala molecular. Entonces puedes imaginar que
cada uno de estos círculos, dependiendo de con
qué estamos tratando, es unión, una molécula o un
átomo. El modelo nos dice cómo estas moléculas,
iones o átomos interactúan entre sí, lo que
determina el estado en que se encuentra la
materia. Pausa este video y piensa cuál de estas
imágenes representa materia en estado sólido,
cuál representa materia en estado líquido y
cuál representa materia en estado gaseoso.
Muy bien. Hay algunos estados que podrían ser
algo obvios para ti. Si imaginas que cada uno
de estos círculos es unión, podrías pensar que
este tipo de estructura representa a los sólidos
iónicos que hemos visto con estructura reticular.
Si imaginas que cada uno de estos círculos son
átomos que están formando enlaces covalentes con
los círculos vecinos, entonces podrías pensar que
se trata de una red covalente sólida. Si imaginas
que cada uno de estos círculos son moléculas y
debido a las fuerzas intermoleculares se han
organizado entre ellas de esta manera regular,
entonces podrías pensar que se trata de un
sólido molecular. También podrías pensar que
cada uno de estos son átomos de metal y todos
comparten el mar de electrones de valencia, y
entonces estamos tratando con un sólido metálico.
Pero no importa qué sea lo que estés imaginando,
es bastante claro que este es un sólido, pues
uno de los principales indicadores de eso es
que no está tomando la forma del contenedor.
Estas moléculas, supongo que se podría decir
estas partículas, no pueden deslizarse unas
sobre otras y tomar la forma del contenedor
en el que se encuentran, como sucedería en un
líquido, y claramente no son capaces de vencer
las fuerzas entre las partículas y moverse
de un lado a otro, lo que veríamos en un gas,
en donde rebotarían por todo el contenedor.
Entonces, esto es claramente un sólido. Ahora,
aquí en la parte inferior izquierda parece que las
partículas están tomando la forma del contenedor,
pueden deslizarse unas sobre otras, pero todavía
hay fuerzas intermoleculares que evitan que se
separen. Entonces, esto es claramente un
líquido. Y en esta otra imagen inferior
derecha puedes imaginar lo que está pasando:
estas partículas, ya sean moléculas o iones,
han podido superar en su mayor parte las fuerzas
intermoleculares entre ellas, así que simplemente
están rebotando, tomando completamente la
forma del contenedor en el que se encuentran,
por lo que esto es un gas. Ahora, ¿qué pasa con
este de aquí? Se ve como un sólido en el sentido
de que no está tomando la forma de su contenedor,
pero también es irregular pues tiene la forma en
que podría esperarse de un líquido, al menos en
un instante en el tiempo; y debido a que no está
tomando la forma de su contenedor y porque estas
moléculas o estas partículas, aunque irregulares,
no se están deslizando entre sí, como podríamos
esperar en un líquido, nos indica que también
es un sólido pero lo llamamos un sólido amorfo.
No tiene esta bonita estructura cristalina como
la que vemos en los sólidos cristalinos. Y hay
muchos ejemplos de sólidos amorfos. La mayoría
de los sólidos que conoces y que son elásticos o
tienen una cualidad elástica son sólidos amorfos.
Por ejemplo, si tuvieras un pedazo de caucho
natural podrías estirarlo y se vería algo así,
pero luego, al soltarlo, volvería a su
estado original, o casi a su estado original;
y la razón por la que se comporta así el caucho
natural es porque está compuesto de polímeros.
Y sólo para imaginar qué es un polímero: esta es
la estructura molecular del caucho natural real,
es una cadena de carbonos unidos a hidrógenos,
y si pudieras alejar esta imagen podrías ver
que estas largas cadenas de carbono con hidrógenos
en el caucho natural se enredan entre sí y forman
este sólido amorfo. No se ve exactamente como
este modelo de partículas que acabamos de ver,
es más, simplemente imagina un montón de hilos
que están todos enredados y si tiras de ellos
se pueden estirar, pero si lo sueltas regresan
casi a donde estaban antes. Ahora, el caucho no
es el único polímero; por ejemplo, los plásticos
que hay a tu alrededor también son polímeros,
y unos pocos son en su mayoría amorfos, algunos
otros son mayormente cristalinos y muchos son los
que llamaríamos semicristalinos, lo que significa
que tienen regiones amorfas y cristalinas.